I thought once again we'd help our  audience members make a sailor  connection by showing some of their  craigslist ads right here on the show  let's check them out right now first up  wanted Breaking Bad DVDs just show the  parts that show you how to cook Matt  [Applause]  here we go free  my wife's tear-stained love letters to  dr. odds  are you a professional dancer who's  confident that she can teach a beginner  the basics of dancing then let's have  sex  [Applause]  all-you-can-eat my homemade 100% organic  beard bacon dig in misconnection you in  your bed having sex with your boyfriend  me in the crawlspace under your house  listening quietly seeking new members  seattle-based all-girl underground hair  cut Fight Club  a man wanted need help digging a  son-in-law size  and finally fools that need to be pitied  I'm here guy  [Applause]  cutting resemblance chubby person should  be proud all right